hi guys it's silver ed again and this is
going to be the last episode of the
season in which I'll finish the park and
do the foliage off screen though sorry
for that leg problems computer also I've
got a cold so I'm sorry if my voice
sounds really bad I probably mentioned
this again in the video because I'm
stupid like that but anyway enjoy the
time-lapse for now
yeah it's foliage on and off the foliage
this Pike has done yet I'm not going to
record the foliage I suppose because
perhaps is not very nice and my computer
isn't very good and problems you know
I'll do some foliage and come back and
you're done all right okay all right
I've done the foliage around Icarus and
I must say it actually looks better than
I expected because for a long time this
area of the park always seemed like it
would be too big and spread out actually
look nice but now that I look at it with
foliage it's actually a lot better I
mean it's pretty cool and I just try to
experiment with those empty little
things in the background I I don't know
what you would call them funny stuff so
I'm just going to continue and do some
other sections of the park right now
and whoa suddenly the entire park is
finished like huh
no this actually took me hours and I'm
really sad that I can record it for my
let's play for a time-lapse maybe I
could have done that but when I tried it
it lagged so much that I couldn't even
work so sorry for that guys but really
foliage just make my Park look ten times
better not saying it's good yeah I am I
like it I'm a delight I mean especially
the river view over here with the wooden
coaster over there and silver at sucks
at angles and nice river nice scenery
and or and then we've got acres in the
background which I'm still going to have
to look at because I've got one problem
with that that will come back on later
the ferris wheel's looking pretty swell
along with the Main Street of course
doesn't really matter that much that
most foliage now but just the fact
leather spoke that there's a forest and
in background now just makes it look a
little bit better and yes I did finish
the backsides of the buildings over here
not like it really matters much because
I've put so much foliage in there just
to cover it all up because I'm pretty
sure people would do that in real life
as well I think this this family coastal
looks a lot better with all the foliage
by the way looks very empty and boring
before but now now it's just a little
bit nicer see how it's pretty cool but
yeah for Icarus I've got a little
problem because this is what this is
what is happening so this is not really
nice it's going all I don't know what
it's doing it looks a lot it looks kinda
nice like this in a way but you see as
soon as that as we as you get into an
inversion it does this so that kind of
sucks as well other camera position same
story and this one as well so going to
have a hard time with that I'm probably
going to use a different CTR or just the
ingame one for the POV but this one
looks amazing though so I will have to
let this one stay for upright footage
but that's just going to be a little bit
harder than but yeah this is the park
right now it's finished so now I'm going
to have to record a video or maybe
someone with ambien
clusion can do the video for me but I'm
not sure if that's actually going to
happen you'll see it later on but anyway
that's it for the for this season but
like I said before I'm not going to stop
my Let's Plays series with this I'm just
going to make a different season with a
different Park or maybe coasters I don't
know what you guys prefer probably a
park though and after that I guess a new
season with another Park so see you next
season guys
you